この家ですね真剣に聞きから
2ヶ月ぐらいがだったんですけども今のところこの新しい家初めはみゅーずめんと
パークの来場者数は
3名でございますありがとうございます
[拍手]
ええええええ
まず母もう by する某レンジに人が来たのはもうもう来た
もう来たおいそこのは2学生さんに見てるか一時たので洋一
そしてそのよさ引越してあの子の家に行ったんですけども
もうちょっとね3人からちょっと動画を見てくださってありがとうございますじゃない
動画を見ている人が3人僕の家に来追記してきまし
非常に迷惑です正直もなんか怖くて外にも出たくないんですよまああんまり
それぐらいでちょっとね家に直接来られると非常に明白っていうことますね
何回も言ってると思うんだよなんだ言ってるんだけどもそれではオレンジに来る奴が
いるあまりをリーヤーも特定してもいいよトップしても ec はじめが同時吸ってる
書くのは買ってもいいんだけども
直接劇
比べるとちょっとで迷惑なんですよ本当にもう僕に年前って公平
寝てピンポン気づかなかったんですけどねてていこうドンドンドンドンドンドンといっ
てそれでも結構長い時間30分
最近そういうなんか視聴者さんが言いにくいってことはなかったのでちょっと気が緩ん
でた
ちょっと気が緩んで寝ちゃって開けると言え
ものだ鉄鋼始めた情報
俺だんっ
そうだけど本物だけども知らないとは言い難いが本当に怖いんですよ前だとちょっと木
グリポーズでお前の話題でも言うなやつって写真とってたんですけどなんかよ動画で
言ってるのにまだ来るって事はちょっとまだダメだなと思ってずれずねもうちょっと
突堤始まってるこの動画を見てのはたち俺の家がわかってくれねぇよ俺んちに来て俺は
何もしないぞ
もうねほんと迷惑だから普通に怒っちゃってる
動くの雄が分かってもネットステーションもいいです僕ははじめチケットは買っても
いいけどいうの周りの写真を撮ったり離婚をしたりずっとどんどんとかねされるとても
メアでなどであるやめてください
とても迷惑なのでで今回でやっぱ怖いんですよ
もしのオレンジが分かってくる人かもし犯罪だとかものを進めてきた時の対象ね今日
ちょっとしそれをしようと思いますよねあれよ
装束で中国で関係ないとオレンジ記者の俺は怒るからねって今回はこちらの防犯カメラ
でそれはもう家に防犯カメの取り付けからなお前ら俺ん家の前に来ると俺は動画を撮っ
て
怒るぞカメラ画像でスマホですぐに見られますということで端まで確認できる防犯
カメラ買ったねこれは今日から家に取り付けて勝手に人の家に来るねバカどもをね俺は
それで寝取るからねこれは怒ってるからそこのすごく性を掘ってただどれ
思ってただろうねちゃんと証拠の5000年もそのまま都合しますこれが防犯彼がです
えっをついてホップこれで後ろの wp そうと三拍子ます hp ターンぽいって
別人としている一夫以南に無線ランルーターが wps ことを押さなきゃいけこれ
なー
ねええええ本 w
なるほど会条例
くどいだろうかわかんない
ええっこれでアプリと連動させれば暗くなるじゃんなんで種族中なるか何もちゃんって
ちょっとちゃんと設定していく1回
なんとか戦術9月1なんですけどちょっとねぇ
めんどくさかったパプリカもうちょっと改善されれば使いやすいと思いますステージ
始める光一スプーンバーン4
やっぱり人と家に入ったようなら30分もどんなするのはとても怖い4判全人があると
いうのは
大人でも子供でも関係なくやっちゃこっ夫大人買っちゃだめだことはやっちゃダメなん
ですそれがやりましょうて運営幹事便しちゃってるからねこれから俺ん家に来る奴は
全員これが録画したじゃあ監視が話しかけてきます
あの今なんかカメラに失活の人影が映ってるんですけども
ちょっとねなんかこの前来た男の子っぽいんでちょっと今回はどうやって勝つんと言っ
てあげましょう見守ってます
ちょっとガツンと言うんで
[拍手]
[音楽]
しています